vamos a comenzar nuevamente tomando ve
un sub espacio vectorial de rn ok este
es un sub espacio vectorial de rn y
también vamos a tener en cuenta vamos a
tener muy presente al complemento
ortogonal de nuestro espacio b que
también por cierto es un sub espacio de
rn y eso lo demostramos ya hace algunos
vídeos entonces también debemos recordar
que la dimensión como relacionamos la
dimensión de ellos es de la siguiente
forma que la dimensión de nuestro
espacio ve más la dimensión de nuestro
espacio be ortogonal el complemento
ortogonal de de esta suma debe ser igual
a n donde n es la dimensión de de rn
verdades es esta dimensión justamente ok
entonces vamos a seguir tratando de
relacionar a b y al ave ortogonal y lo
primero que nos podríamos preguntar es
bueno habrá algún elemento que se
encuentre en ambos espacios
una pregunta justa vamos a tratar de
resolverla entonces
supongamos vamos a suponer que existe
algún elemento que se encuentra en ambos
digamos que existe un vector x que se
encuentre primero en nuestro espacio b y
también vamos a suponer que este x se
encuentra en nuestro espacio de
ortogonal ok esto esto último que nos
está diciendo todos los elementos del
complemento ortogonal de b son aquellos
que al multiplicarlos por cualquier
elemento del sub espacio b nos da cero
en entonces en este caso como x
pertenece a este a este conjunto
entonces vamos a tener que x punto b es
igual a 0 para cualquier para todo para
todo de vector que se encuentra en
nuestro sub espacio muy bien ahora aquí
tenemos otra cuestión estamos suponiendo
que x se encuentra en nuestro sub
espacio entonces x puede caber muy bien
en este en la posición que juega b
sí sí este esta vez lo sustituimos por
la equis vamos a tener que x punto x es
igual a 0 pero quién es x punto x pues
esto no es otra cosa más que la magnitud
o la norma de x al cuadrado y si nos
dice que la norma al cuadrado es cero
quiere decir que la norma es cero y si
la única no es y si la norma es cero el
único vector que puede satisfacer esta
condición sólo puede ser uno y ese
vector es el vector cero entonces a x no
le queda de otra más que ser el vector
cero ok entonces si consideramos un
vector que se encuentre en ambos solo
puede resultar ser el vector 0 esto en
términos con juntistas lo podemos
escribir de la siguiente forma digamos
que tenemos aquí nuestro sub espacio b y
queremos ver cuáles son todos aquellos
con los cuales coincide con él con el
complemento ortogonal está volteada como
como montecito no es otra cosa más que
la intersección
es decir en qué parte se traslapan se
enciman estos dos conjuntos y la
intersección o los elementos que se
encuentran en ambos es un conjunto de un
solo elemento y es el vector cero ok
entonces cómo se vería esto digamos con
algunos dibujitos por ejemplo aquí
tienen ustedes a todo el espacio rn este
es todo rn y digamos que por aquí vamos
a pintar con azul vamos a pintar con
azul digamos que aquí tenemos a nuestro
sub espacio b también tenemos por ahí a
nuestro complemento ortogonal digamos
que ese este y que resulta que el único
punto en donde ambos se intersectan es
uno es un único punto éste es el peor
tonal y de hecho este punto de aquí este
punto el único d en donde se intersectan
no es otra cosa más que el vector cero
ok esto es digamos viéndolo con algunos
dibujitos
y bueno ahora lo que vamos a hacer es
ver si hay más propiedades que
relacionen al espacio b ya su
complemento ortogonal entonces vamos a
partir ahora suponiendo que que
conocemos la dimensión del espacio b
digamos que la dimensión de nuestro
espacio b es k ok y recordemos que que
la dimensión no es otra cosa más que el
número de elementos que tiene la base en
una base de un sub espacio es el
conjunto más pequeño de de vectores
linealmente independientes que generan a
todo este espacio correcto eso es lo que
nos daría una base entonces también
sabemos qué bueno que b es un
subconjunto de rn que de hecho es un sub
espacio y también sabemos que el
complemento ortogonal de b es un sub
espacio de rn ambos son de hecho
subespacios y sabemos por esta relación
entonces que la dimensión la dimensión
del complemento ortogonal debe pues
al sumarle que nos debe dar n por lo
tanto esto puede debe ser n menos k si
sumamos n menos acá si a esto le sumamos
que entonces n - k mas k nos queda
simplemente en ok entonces les voy a ir
diciendo a donde quiero llegar quiero
ver si combinando estas estos dos estas
dos propiedades podemos construir una
base para todo rnp que voy a hacer un
poquito más claro digamos que tenemos
que conocemos la base del conjunto b
digamos que este tiene base de 1 de 2
etcétera y tenemos acá vectores ok
digamos que este es una base base de fe
y tenemos también alguna otra base por
ejemplo que tenemos la base de de
ortogonal digamos vamos a llamarle a
estos w tenemos w
también w 2 y como son en menos acá pues
tendremos n
de estos vectores ok y esto es una base
base del complemento ortogonal debe
entonces
vamos a ver si juntando estos dos estas
dos bases podríamos hacer una base
completa para todo rn porque tendríamos
dos conjuntos uno de cada elementos y
otro de n menos k que en total nos dan
en elementos entonces la pregunta es si
estos si juntamos estos dos conjuntos
podríamos obtener una base una base para
todo rn y bueno vamos a tratar de
resolver esa pregunta que íbamos a bajar
un poco
entonces vamos a primero ver si es así
juntando estos dos conjuntos tenemos que
sean linealmente independientes ok
entonces consideremos una combinación
lineal digamos que tengo c1 b1 más de
dos dedos más toda una combinación de
estos ves más seca bk ok y además voy a
sumarle alguna combinación de estos
dobles porque entonces vamos a sumarle
también vamos a ponerle que sean las
constantes des de uno
wv uno más de dos w
más etcétera de n
k w n
ok y vamos a suponer que toda esta
combinación lineal nos da exactamente el
vector 0 ok entonces esto es lo que nos
estaría diciendo es que bueno en
principio sabemos que si hay una
solución si por ejemplo todas las
constantes es y las veces son 0 esto
tiene sentido porque tendríamos 000 que
sumamos puros ceros y nos da el vector 0
la pregunta es si hay alguna otra
solución que no sea la trivial es decir
que no sean todas las constantes cero si
no es así entonces tenemos que todo este
conjunto de vectores completito es
linealmente independiente y después
veríamos que genera todo rn verdad
entonces con esto podríamos ir avanzando
para probar qué es una base para todo el
espacio
entonces lo que vamos a hacer ahora es
considerar vamos a pasar todas todos los
los vectores wv los vamos a pasar del
lado derecho y entonces como nos queda
vamos a tener c1 b1
c 2 b 2 + varias cosas aquí más seca de
acá y esto va a ser igual si nosotros
pasamos todos estos vectores del lado
derecho los tenemos que pasar restando
verdad entonces restamos todos estos que
serían de 1w 1 + de 2w 2 etcétera más de
n menos k w n menos acá muy bien
entonces vamos ahora a qué es esto
bueno esto de aquí esto de aquí es una
combinación lineal de vectores que son
base de nuestro psuv espacio b qué
quiere decir esto que si yo por ejemplo
le pongo de nombre vamos a llamarle a
este número o perdón a este vector x x
va a hacerse uno de uno más de dos de
dos
todos estos más seca beca quiere decir
esto
por supuesto que entonces x como es una
combinación lineal de elementos de la
base de nuestro espacio ve pues a x no
le queda otra cosa más que pertenecer a
b y eso es porque los sub espacios
vectoriales son cerrados bajo sumas y
bajo multiplicación por escalares de
hecho son cerrados bajo combinaciones
lineales entonces esta combinación
lineal pertenece a b entonces a éste le
llamamos x
y por otro lado este numerito x nos dice
que es una combinación lineal de
vectores w.bush que son base del
complemento ortogonal de b entonces todo
esto que tenemos aquí a la derecha digo
quizás se puede confundir un poquito el
menos y demás en el punto es que si si
tú multiplicas este menos por todos los
sumandos te queda una combinación lineal
de wv de los vectores w entonces esto es
alguna combinación lineal
combinación
escribirlo completo una combinación
lineal
de vectores de la base de habíamos dicho
de del complemento ortogonal de b
entonces son combinación lineal de
vectores de la base del complemento
ortogonal de b
entonces si x por un lado también es
esta combinación lineal quiere decir que
x por ser una combinación lineal de
elementos de la base del complemento
ortogonal de b quiere decir que también
está en el complemento ortogonal
entonces x está en el complemento
ortogonal de b ok entonces y eso fue con
lo que empecé este vídeo porque yo
empecé hablando de que si teníamos algún
elemento que se encuentra en ambos
espacios en ambos sub espacios no le
queda de otra más que ser el vector 0
verdad aquí tenemos que x forzosamente
tiene que ser el vector 0 entonces aquí
concluimos que si expresamos de esta
forma x necesariamente es el vector 0
ahora repasemos esto porque si tenemos
esto de aquí
si tenemos esto de aquí
tenemos una combinación lineal y ahora
sabemos que esta x déjenme déjenme
borrar esta x
ya sabemos que es 0 verdad entonces
tenemos que 0 es igual a una combinación
lineal de elementos de la base de
nuestro espacio b pero sabemos que estos
por ser una base son linealmente
independientes y la una de las
definiciones de que sean una colección
de vectores linealmente independientes
es que si tiene una una combinación
lineal que nos da 0 sólo puede ser que
las constantes que por las cuales
estamos multiplicando a los vectores
sean únicamente 0 entonces de aquí por
ser una base obtenemos que todas estas
constantes deben ser 0
entonces de aquí obtenemos que ese 1
c2 etcétera todas estas constantes secas
son
o bueno deben ser deben ser
deben ser
ok eso por un lado ahora del otro lado
también tenemos una combinación lineal
de vectores pero ahora estos vectores de
hecho son la base de el complemento
ortogonal del complemento ortogonal y
nos da 0 y es el mismo argumento tenemos
una combinación lineal de vectores
linealmente independientes que nos da 0
por lo tanto todas estas constantes
deben ser 0 bueno en realidad uno puede
distribuir al menos y decir menos de uno
es cero menos de 20 menos de n menos cae
0 pero bueno menos de 1 igual a 0 y eso
significa que de uno tiene que ser cero
entonces todas estas todas estas también
se hacen cero
entonces b1 b2 etcétera hasta de
elementos que deben ser también pero
deben ser 0 muy bien ahora regresemos un
poquito acá arriba vamos a regresar nos
un poquito vamos a regresar a nuestro
problema original que estábamos tratando
de analizar que que era esta que estoy
marcando en azul fíjense queríamos ver
al menos ahorita si juntamos estos estos
dos conjuntos que son bases si al
juntarlos podríamos obtener una base
completa para él para el espacio de rn
entonces dijimos bueno pues vamos a ver
primero si son linealmente
independientes entonces damos una
combinación lineal de todos estos
vectores que nos dé 0 y ahora resulta
que
no pudo ser de otra forma más que todos
estos de los de las constantes tienen
que ser cero y eso lo vimos porque al
expresar lo de esta forma se iguala
vamos a hacer o por ser linealmente
independientes esto me daba 0 y por otro
lado también me daba 0 y sólo le
quedaban serán las constantes a todas
ser 0 por lo tanto regresando a nuestro
problema original ya que teníamos una
combinación lineal dada y resultó que
todos tienen que ser 0 eso
inmediatamente me está diciendo que el
conjunto formado por ambas bases es
linealmente independiente ok entonces
vamos a notar eso tengo yo mi conjunto
formado por vamos a hacerlo con con los
colores que ya tenía
por ejemplo mi conjunto formado por b1
b2
todos estos todos estos hasta beca este
digamos nuestra primera base y después
le juntamos o extendemos esta base con
todos estos dobles le juntamos w1 wv2
etcétera hasta w n menos acá todo este
conjunto en donde ya funcione digamos
estas dos bases es un conjunto
linealmente independiente linealmente
independiente ok
un conjunto linealmente independiente y
de hecho vamos a ver qué es una base de
rn eso es lo que queremos llegar a que
no solo es un conjunto linealmente
independiente sino que además va a
llegar a ser una base ok entonces vamos
a repasar un poquito de estas
propiedades supongamos que tenemos un
sub espacio sube espacio de dimensión
vamos a decir n
dimensión dimensión en ok tenemos un sub
espacio de dimensiones y vamos a suponer
que tenemos tenemos n vectores
linealmente independientes ok tenemos en
efectores n vectores linealmente ya sólo
lo voy a escribir como l y sale l
linealmente independientes y que son
elementos del psuv espacio que son
elementos
o miembros elementos o miembros del psuv
espacio
ok tenemos estos en elementos de
vectores linealmente independientes del
sub espacio entonces nosotros ya sabemos
que el conjunto de los n vectores que
estos en electores linealmente
independientes es una base del psuv
espacio verdad es una base del psuv
espacio por qué
necesitamos forzosamente si las
dimensiones n necesitamos
escribí mal necesitamos para generar al
menos n pero es el mínimo número verdad
con menos vectores no puedo generar un
espacio de dimensión n por lo tanto este
conjunto es una base del psuv espacio ok
entonces en particular podríamos pensar
en rn podríamos pensar en rn rn como un
sub espacio o que digamos rn es un sub
espacio
de qué dimensión pues tiene dimensiones
de verdad aquí nos está indicando
entonces este es un sub espacio de
dimensión n que lo podemos escribir de
esta forma que la dimensión de rn es
justamente eso n ok y entonces qué es lo
que vamos a tomar consideremos un vector
a rojito vamos a ponerlo con un rojito
digamos que tenemos un vector
tenemos un vector a elemento de rn ok
entonces como tenemos aquí
y esto resultó ser un conjunto
linealmente independiente pero cuántos
elementos tiene esto
esto tiene cada elementos de estos rojos
y n cada elementos de estos amarillos si
los sumamos en total son n lectores
linealmente independientes ok entonces
como además el espacio rn tiene
dimensión n por esta observación esto
inmediatamente ya es una base ok de
hecho vamos a escribir lo que todo esto
de aquí todo esto de aquí ya es una base
esto
es una base una base y por supuesto es
una base de rn verdad ok ok entonces si
es una base y nos tomamos cualquier
vector de rn entonces este vector yo lo
puedo escribir como una combinación
lineal de elementos de la base entonces
puede ser vamos a ponerle vamos a
ponerle otro nombre a las constantes
para que no se confunda como que
teníamos arriba digamos que es
digamos b 1 por b
más de 2 por b 2
quién sabe cuántos sean son cada dijimos
beca ok aquí tenemos estos elementos de
la base y necesitamos también elementos
de estos vamos a llamarle por ejemplo
1 w 1 + 2 w 2
más varias otras cosas e n menos k w n -
k le cambié posee otras constantes para
que no se confunda con lo que teníamos
arriba ok entonces si ya pudimos
expresar cualquier vector del espacio r
n de esta forma ahora fijémonos en lo
siguiente y fijémonos principalmente en
los colores estos de aquí estos de aquí
es una combinación lineal de elementos
de nuestro psuv espacio b entonces esto
aquí sí si agrupamos todos estos es un
vector pero que donde vive pues este
vector vive en nuestro psuv espacio
porque es cerrado bajo combinaciones
lineales entonces este vector que le voy
a llamar v
este vive en nuestro psuv espacio ve
ahora podemos pensar exactamente lo
mismo con estos otros vectores porque
estos otros vectores pues serán algún
vector digamos equis pero es una
combinación lineal de vectores que viven
en nuestro este sub espacio de de
ortogonal verdad donde lo había puesto
aquí esta verdad todos estos viven en el
complemento ortogonal debe por lo tanto
en cualquier combinación lineal de ellos
vive
el complemento ortogonal debe porque es
un sub espacio eso ya lo habíamos visto
en algunos en algunos vídeos antes ok
entonces fíjense muy bien cómo es que
ahora puedo reescribir a porque este es
un vector b y este es un vector x
entonces a lo puedo expresar como un
vector b más un vector x ok que es lo
que acabo de hacer me está diciendo que
cualquier vector de rn lo puedo expresar
como una suma de dos vectores uno que
vive en b y el otro que vive en su
complemento ortogonal y ese es una idea
muy interesante de cómo podemos
descomponer vectores de esta forma ahora
una pregunta que te puedes estar
haciendo inmediatamente si esta
expresión es única
ok será única
es decir qué pasaría si yo puedo
expresar como la suma de dos vectores o
uno que viven de otro que vive en el
complemento ortogonal pero que lo puedo
hacer de dos formas distintas esto es
por ejemplo
vamos a escribirlo supongamos que no es
única primero
supongamos
supongamos que no es única
que no es
única si no es única entonces voy a
tener a mi vector
y tengo mi vector a que lo puedes
escribir como un b1 más x1 pero también
lo puedo escribir como b 2 + x2 donde
donde vamos a tener que suponer que
bueno si a esta en rn
entonces estamos estaremos diciendo que
los ve que los ves b1 y b2 viven en
nuestro sub espacio b y que x1 y x2
viven en el complemento ortogonal
entonces qué es lo que podemos hacer
en esta en esta ocasión
bueno si el b 2 lo pasamos del otro lado
restando
y el x1 del lado derecho también
restando es decir vamos a tener el lado
de este lado b 1 - b 2 sería igual a x2
y el x 1 lo pasamos del otro lado
entonces me queda igual a x2 menos x 1
ok que es lo que he logrado con esto
fíjense si yo llamo a este vector z
digamos que esto es un zeta ceta es es
la resta de dos vectores que viven en
nuestro sub espacio b entonces esto nos
está diciendo cómo es un sub espacio que
z vive también en nuestro sub espacio b
ok esto es la resta de dos vectores que
viven en b como ve es un sub espacio
vectorial esto vive todavía en ve y
permanece por otro lado z
es también la resta de dos vectores pero
estos dos vectores viven en el
complemento ortogonal que habíamos dicho
que el complemento ortogonal es un sub
espacio eso ya lo hemos demostrado
en vídeos anteriores entonces como es un
sub espacio es cerrado bajo bajo
adicción o bueno si restamos los
vectores es un caso especial de la
adición verdad entonces estamos aquí
diciendo que z se encuentra también en
el complemento ortogonal de nuestro
espacio ahora porque empecé el vídeo con
todo esto porque en el vídeo
al inicio dijimos que el único elemento
que puede estar en ambos conjuntos es el
vector cero y aquí justamente encontré
un vector que vive en ambos entonces
esto me da de forma gratuita que el
vector tiene que ser únicamente el cero
ok entonces esto debe ser igual a cero
que es lo que tenemos ahora que b1 b2 es
igual a cero y x2 menos x1 es igual a
cero entonces vamos a escribir esto por
un lado tenemos que d
v 2 es igual a cero y si pasamos de 2
sumando del otro lado vamos a tener que
ver uno es igual a b 2
eso es una bonita observación ahora aquí
tenemos también también tenemos que x 1
- x 2
es igual a 0 verdad es esto
bueno aquí
en realidad no importa mucho voy a
corregirlos los subíndices aquí debería
ser x 2 - x 1 es igual a 0 pero si esto
es igual a 0 podemos pasar x 1 sumando
del otro lado y tenemos que x 2 va a ser
igual a x 1 entonces que fue lo que
ocurrió al final que si yo no expresé de
dos formas distintas resulta que los dos
vectores que lo componen pues no son
otra cosa más que iguales es decir esto
debe ser igual a esto y x1 debe ser
igual a x2 entonces la descomposición de
este vector tuvo que ser necesariamente
única